earlier this month a Fulton County  Superior Court judge determined that  Nick Gordon is to pay over 36 million  dollars in damages in the wrongful death  suit of whitney houston's daughter but  today he's remembering the late singer  sharing a photo of the two with the  caption learned so much from this  amazing woman miss you so much Gordon  was a no-show in court in September 2016  and has not been criminally charged in  Bobbi Kristina's death in a previous  statement to ET a Bobbi Brown said he  was pleased by the outcome adding quote  I do know that mr. Gordon will be unable  to slander my daughter's name in the  future or obtain any benefits from the  use of Chrissy's name is it hard to get  closer when you don't know what happened  yes definitely Bobbi Kristina spent  nearly six months in a coma after being  found facedown in a bathtub in her  Georgia home she died in hospice care on  July 26 2015 at age 22  you